all right folks here we are
July QA so I decided to do this public
again because with a lot of fun last
time and I so we'll see how it goes this
time so before we start I want to
reiterate something that I talked about
I'm going to start making patron only
videos once a month I'm going to do it
on fairy tales I did it on a video on
Jack and the Beanstalk and now I'm going
the next video I'm going to make will be
probably on The Princess and the pea and
so I'm hoping to go through a lot of the
stories that interest me fairy tales and
traditional stories legends I might also
ask for the patrons to vote for which
stories are interesting to them and the
reason why I'm doing that I'll be
totally honest with you guys is because
since the flood I've been really
struggling to be able to carve I don't
have a workshop for a while and down my
tools now I kind of have my tools but
I'm working outside under a tent so it's
kind of iffy when it rains I can't
really continue I have to go back in so
it's been really it's I feel like I'm
kind of adrift let's say and the one
thing I can do is make videos as you've
seen I've been putting out more content
and I intend to kind of try to keep that
up as long as my carving so long because
I can't totally get into the carving
properly it seems like possibly a
workshop we'll be able to be saved that
I won't have to tear down and rebuild it
that I can just decontaminate and
hopefully go back to my workshop when we
get back to our house so so in order to
so in order to kind of thank the patrons
and encourage people who were on the
verge of maybe becoming a patron I'm
gonna do these monthly these extra
monthly videos so alright guys so
besides that I had to talk with Paul van
der clay today it was it was one of the
best talks we had I think usually we go
for an hour usually I don't like to go
over now over a conversation but this
conversation went out for like an hour
and 45 minutes so I'll be putting that
out in the next few days maybe next week
not sure
um I had another conversation with
someone an expert on Tunisia ah a lot of
people and tell me about your news aha
so he's putting that out soon as well so
there's a lot of stuff coming down the
pipeline that I'm excited to share with
you guys so I'm going to I'm going to
start the the the questions with my
website so you go and what we'll do is
is this time last time I really
struggled to - if those who wanted to do
the super chat thing I kind of really
struggled with it but I figured out how
to keep track of these super chat things
so if people want to do the super chat
thing I will try to stay on top of it
and when I'm done with all the patron
questions then I'll go into that so
alright here we go
let me just make sure that I got the
right question all right so so believes
one two three four asks hi Jonathan
I wanted to know what you thought of
Jordan Peterson's understanding of
individualism and how Jesus is seen as
the ultimate example of the individual
the more that I tried to understand the
Bible and different writings and
discussions it is not individual that I
believe is at the forefront but rather
the family which I believe is partly at
the heart of the Trinity so rather than
just being called to be an individual
Carl called me a part of a family in
order to bring life into the world like
God brought life into us thanks and I
hope you were able to understand my
question yes I totally understand your
question I think that I think that part
there's a part of the problem is words a
lot of the lot of Orthodox thinkers and
a lot of traditional mind thinkers have
tended to separate or oppose the notion
of the individual and the person you
could say and and the way we could
separate it is the the individual is
seen as this as kind of like the this
disc or you know as this one chord this
kind of ISIL
core which has to develop and and then
the world kind of is built on that have
you know the freedom of the site of the
freedom of the individual responsibility
of the eventual individual all of that
seems to to define the person as as this
dislike this atomized core you could say
but it I want to be careful because it's
not necessarily that the notion of the
person in the Orthodox tradition is a
lot more like your own notion of the
family which is that you could say in a
way that the person is on the one hand
the particular of a nature but it is
that the particular of that nature to
the extent that it is also capable of
being in communion with other beings and
so the the person as a you know years
apart is the particular just like the
individual is the particular but seen as
a part of a whole scene as being in
communion with others and so in that
sense that that's why the Trinity is the
ultimate image of the infinite in that
sense but there is definitely a theology
of the person in orthodoxy and
traditional Christianity and there are
some aspects of the theology of the
person which could be used to to move
into what we now called the individual
or an individualism and I think that I
think we also have to be careful and I
might have fallen into that trap as well
I think that a lot of people have said
that Jordan's vision of the individual
is a kind of individualism in the sense
that the modern world understands it but
I think that Jordan the fact that Jordan
sees the individual instead of seeing
the individual as let's say the one on
which all rights are put you know that
that you we all have these rights and
everything he tends to view it more in
terms of responsibility and the idea
that you as an individual you have to
take upon yourself responsibility for
everything for all all the
the evils of the world and you know
although it's funny that some people
have criticized him for that and I see
Christians criticize him for that for
example like Vox they criticized him for
that but if you read the Church Fathers
and if you read the Saints you will find
the Saints doing that all the time that
they actually take the sins of the other
onto themselves they they take the blame
of others unto themselves they accept
blame when there is no blame to be had
and that is seen in a certain manner as
imitating Christ but there's also
something metaphysical about it where
this idea of accepting all the blame
when you're innocent it it's hard to
talk about this because there's
something very kind of something very
contradictory about it but the idea of
accepting blame when you're innocent
when it shows is your freedom it shows
to what extent you're actually free from
the pull of the outside world because
your tendency would be to defend
yourself why do you want to defend
yourself you want to defend yourself
because you hold on to this idea of who
you are you want to you know you could
be defending yours I'm not saying we
shouldn't defend ourselves in the world
but in terms of spiritual realization
you could say that if you're able to
accept blame without defending yourself
it means that ultimately you don't care
what the others think of you that you
only you you'd care more to know that
you're innocent than to prove your
innocence to others and to depend on
their perception of you and so there's
something very powerful about that which
is found in Christianity which seems to
have some echoes in what Jordan is
talking about but I do think at the same
time that there is a difference between
between the way the jordan Peterson the
way the jordan peterson talks about it
and the way that that the church fathers
have talked about it all right and so
Pat
asks good evening all right this is a
really long thing I'm not sure this is a
question pat Shire
all right so so so Pat kind of tells his
story I'm not gonna read this story I
also you know he kind of tells his his
his basic story of you know moving into
angsty atheism in high school like a lot
of you guys that have followed me you
know and a lot of people have gone
through and the kind of his vague
spirituality and he's moving towards
okay so he says I can maybe read a
little bit of to it he says since my two
years in grad school as a physical
oceanography student to bed trips on
marijuana catalyze my curiosity about
God so he kind of moved in that
direction read Jordan Peters's biblical
lectures and then for the first time I
saw a glimmer of light in these stories
I've been consumed with curiosity after
finding your channel and your brothers
book this has been one of the most
difficult struggles in my life as I saw
used to thinking materially I've tried
to satisfy this aspect of myself by
reading books such as the language of
God a scientist presents evidence for
belief my confusion may be due to the
perplexing amount of denominations let
alone other religious claims it all
seems arbitrary in some sense although I
don't feel completely capable of
differentiating so what wisdom would you
grab me about my struggle with faith and
God it looks like I can't I can't find
God from an intellectual perspective
that I'm used to it isn't necessary to
find God personally in order to come to
faith are there some stories similar to
my journey that may help words can't
convey how helpful you have been thus
far thank you so thanks Pat for that
that that kind of little testimony in
your question you know yes it is it is
it is confusing to notice all the
different denominations it is it can be
frustrating to see that and it can be
you you cannot totally find God
intellectually you can have glimmers of
it but but in the end there is something
there is an interesting thing that
Bishop Aaron talked about when he was
talking to Jordan Peterson when he
talked about how I think it was origin
who when someone came up to him and
asked a lot of these questions about the
faith and everything and and he said
something like give alms
that's how you will disk find God give
alms and you'll find God so there is an
aspect to which to enter into you know
to take that little glimmer to not to
not let's say pretend don't don't don't
lie to yourself you know
don't pretend something but there is for
example something about worship this
idea of expressing gratitude expressing
gratitude for the things in your life
and to to kind of approach God and say
just in that way to just thank God for
for the things that that you that you
see that are good around you to then try
to to help those that are in need all of
these little things are also part of
finding of finding that experience or
discovering the the the connection with
the divine and you know so I think that
those are things that you can do that
you kind of can start to do in order to
to to move forward and you know I know
it's tough in terms of denominations I
would say you know I I do believe that
that orthodoxy offers the most complete
vision of Christianity but I know that
that's not available for everybody and
it's difficult for a lot of people and
and I would say to just move step by
step with open eyes and with your mind
open you know to to to to go to a church
you know to a church that's near nearby
if you there's no Orthodox Church go to
a Catholic Church go to a church that
looks not too wacky not too crazy that
it looks kind of you know and and just
move step by step continue to read
continue to to ask the questions try to
be grateful try to be grateful to God
for the for the things around you and
and that and that's just gonna move you
step by step and I think that that I
think that just
kind of hoping that it's all gonna come
together for you you know one thing
that's not gonna happen
I mean it has happened to people before
but you can't expect that to happen
um so I wish you the best on your
journey all right here we go so Djoser
7:33 asks hi Jonathan could you talk
about the symbolism of disability both
physical and mental and how that might
relate to Jesus's miracles for example
the healing of the man born blind and
the exercising of the Duma that I don't
know you pronounce that in english
demoniac so Christ what Christ comes to
do part of what Christ comes to do is to
restore things he comes to make things
right to bring things back to what they
should be and and you can see it in a
lot of the way that he he talks about
things what one of the reasons why
Christ is so attacks hypocrisy so much
is because he is because hypocrisy is it
break between heaven and earth it's a
break between the meaning and the actual
manifestation and so healing a person is
part of is part of that and so the fact
that Christ heals people means that he's
uniting heaven and earth he's he's
showing to a to a certain extent that
he's the creator but he's also he's also
you know and there's this interesting
idea like the idea that the man born
blind especially where you ask people
ask Christ you know you know who sinned
you know who sinned in order for this
man to have been blind and and you know
and it's not a simple stupid question to
ask in the sense that when we see
someone who has a disability we we
immediately understand that that this
there's something lacking that this
person has something that is that is
lacking that is not working properly in
their life you know to deny that is to
lie to the person and to lie to reality
you know and so and so the idea is that
that is a part of sinfulness
remember that sinfulness is missing the
mark and so this is what a person is and
so and then you have someone who for one
reason or another can't use their legs
and so they're missing they're missing
something human they're missing the mark
of what it is to be a person a full
human person and and the the the
question of the the disciples is like
who is the blame
like how who's to blame for this and he
said his parents sinned in a moral sense
for that this situation this kind of
sinful result comes about and Christ's
answer is their most amazing answer
Christ answer is the answer that I've
been telling you guys from the beginning
Christ slips it you know and he sees in
this person the results of death you can
see it that way more than sin itself
that that he that in their body they
have the result of death you know the
the wage of sin is death the wage of
missing the mark is this lack is this
decomposition this breaking a part of
what a person is and so Christ takes
that Lac and he he says no this person
has been born blind so that so that God
could be glorified and so he turns it
into glory flips death into glory and
then he returns light to the person and
heals that person makes them hold and
then that you can imagine something like
that person in being made whole by
Christ by being by their blindness being
being taken away they're at a higher
place than they then they would be if
they had never been blind in the first
place and that's the surprise of
salvation but that's the surprise of the
flip where where death can be changed
into something even higher than then
what was before so I think that that
that that's that that's something that
you see and and interestingly enough you
see in the Orthodox faith you see
something about that in the sense of
some some of the the the Saints are are
kind are considered
they're kind of simple people and
therefore some of the fools for Christ
for example they seemed to have been
mentally handicapped they seem to have
been people who who were somehow
mentally meant you know that they didn't
have all their means you could say but
the the orthodoxy in them a kind of
purity and a kind of something
manifesting itself in that person that
actually shows us the kingdom of God you
know and it's interesting because you if
you meet sometimes people that are that
are mentally handicapped not not
everyone but but sometimes you meet
those people and they have a kind of in
a Lea belay
you know this kind of simple joy that is
is actually very beautiful and is very
powerful and and and it is something
that we would be good to learn to
develop this kind of simplicity and this
capacity to to find joy in the smallest
thing and to find joy in the world
there's these stories of these Russian
saints of a of a man who would who's who
would just come and he would just ring
the church bells and he would just be
completely fascinated by this church
bell he could just ring it over and over
and it would find this this immense joy
and just ringing the church bell you
know and that person you know which was
declared as a holy man and so but
there's something about that there's
something about the possibility also of
that lack in a person that it can show
us something higher if you see it in the
proper manner hopefully that that
answers that
all right so Wes Gilbert asks hi
Jonathan can you talk a little about the
concept of noose in the Christian
tradition what it is and the role it
plays in our understanding God and the
world so the notion of the noose is is
very simple I mean it's not simple the
notion of the noose is the idea is
spirit is something like wouldn't say
Paul talks of the the body the soul and
the spirit you could use the word news
for that that is it is the it
the super irrational capacity yeah and
it's difficult because people in the
modern world don't don't think that we
don't we don't believe that it exists
most people don't believe that it exists
and and and it's the capacity to be in
direct contact with reality you could
say it that way or to it's the intellect
it's the intellect --nt in the the the
highest sphere and so it's the capacity
to intuit a reality something it is hard
to give to give words but and the news
is that which can contemplate God to the
extent that that's possible you know and
so and so we have that and so so the way
that I try to try to help people kind of
get a sense of the news because like I
said we don't we don't have we struggle
to have access to that but I think that
we do sometimes like sometimes you have
a an intuition an aha moment an
intuition that no rational method has
brought you to you know when you glimpse
something and I think everybody has
those scientists have those you know
artists have those the hunch this this
thing that the slips and it's like you
can't explain there is you weren't you
didn't do this this like rational
process to get to this this intuition
and this intuition is like a flash of
light it-it's like this flash of light
and I think that that's the the way that
that the modern person still has access
to the news and so one of the things
that I try to do and you probably so if
you kind of know what the news is that's
something that I've been that I've been
trying to to do which is to
say things in a way to bring patterns
next to each other in a little dance and
the what I'm hoping to do is that the
place where those patterns come together
I don't I don't explicitly talk about it
but I'm like looking at you and I'm
thinking okay can you make that jump can
you jump and then that jump that
intuition when it's like you know your
eyes flash you see it in people's eyes
when it happens you know like this flash
this understanding that I think is a
little contact with the news um and but
I think that I think that of course the
Church Fathers develop their develop the
noose you know they purify the news you
could say and so reducing distraction
you know this idea of paying attention
of paying attention to yourself of
attending to your sins attending to your
heart
attending to God all of these images of
attention are there to reduce our other
reduce the chaos on the fringe and move
in move in move in to this point the
spark which is the news this spark of
light you could could call it something
like the image of God and you or the
Christ in you all of those things have
to do with with the news so but it's
hard to talk about because I don't live
in the news you know I mean I I have
glimpses of it like most of you do and I
think that I think that that's just you
know it's that if the disease of the
modern world it's very difficult for
stipler to purify the news
all right so david Flores asks what is
the symbolic meaning of Stags in stories
they often seem to be being killed by
hounds or other small predators is it a
pattern of revolution so the stag is
obviously not a pattern of revolution
itself the stag is usually a flash it's
usually that sign you know you have
these images of the White Stag for
example in the story of st. Eustace
Saint said to stash we say in French I
don't know st. Eustace in English how
you say it the story of Santa stache who
sees a white stag in the forest with a
cross in its antlers you know and our
several stories of several Saints but
not only Saints but in in a mythical
different mythical stories you have this
idea of the white stag which appears you
know and becomes like a beacon or a sign
or something that wake awakes you to to
something deeper to to your identity to
some longing to something and so I think
that the that that in that sense the
white stag or the stag because it and
because of its horns which is like a
crown has something to do with that
royal spirit or the the the perceiving
of the meaning the perceiving of
something dignified something high
something elevated you know um and so
the image that you mentioned of which I
don't know examples of those but this
image of the stag being killed by hounds
or small predators ganging up on the
stag and bringing it down that is
definitely a pattern of revolution that
is definitely an image of a revolution
of the of the earth you know kind of
coming up and grabbing you know the
monster from below which comes and takes
down the hides the the glimmer of light
you know kind of concealed it in the
earth is definitely that's definitely
right so I hope that answers that all
right so we are done with the the
website let's go to subscribe star
alright so Christian Chad asks how's
your graphic novel coming along very
excited to see Christian art that is not
over-the-top and preachy like many
Christian movies what do you think
religious artists are creator creators
get wrong when they are making products
like that ah so the graphic novel is
coming it slowed down a little bit a
little bit because cord Nielsen the
artist who is working on it I just had a
baby not very long ago and so obviously
that will slow him down because he's
doing it in his is fair time and so and
so uh you know I mean I mean hoping that
it's gonna come back we have the first
15 pages finished and inked and the
whole graphic novels about 120 pages and
so hopefully we're gonna just keep
moving moving and you know I don't know
when it's going to come out but
we'll probably do is you know kind of
comic skate style when we get into
production where we're close to the the
coloring or you know the binding or
whatever then we'll probably do it as a
crowdfunding and then people can order
in advance and that can give us the
funds to to print it to do all that we
need to do in order to get to get that
to people so so the thing is what do
religious art of the creators get wrong
when they make the the preachy Christian
movies it's I think I talked about this
before then it's that they don't
understand Christianity they don't
understand the depth of Christianity
they don't understand the patterns of
Christianity they only see Christianity
as exactly that as a message that has to
be preached that you have to accept in
order to be saved
whatever that means that you go to
heaven I don't even know what those
words mean anymore I mean I know what
they mean I don't know what they mean
when people use them so that you don't
go to hell and you go to heaven and so
and so you know there's a large swath of
the american or 'the american church
which believes that the only function of
the church is to evangelize that the
churches reason to exist is to
evangelize to other people in order to
save them from hell and get them to have
it and so because of that that will
taint everything they'll take everything
there's no sense of the communion of the
saints no sense of the mystical union of
the bride and the groom no sense that
that the church is the the let's say the
the light of the world in the sense that
it is that that communion that
liturgical life that that sacramentality
is actually the glue which binds things
together and that without that things
scatter and break apart and so none of
that is is perceived and so that's why
the stories are horrible and that's why
on the other hand something like
Dostoyevsky who or or or toking who
won't necessarily make explicitly
Christian books or Christian texts but
because they are they understand the
deep patterns they understand the
stories and and and the structures and
they're immersed in it then they can
write stories in that
world and they end up being good and so
yeah I hope that that that hope that my
story is going to be like that it's not
it's not preachy that's for sure I just
hope it's a good story
ha ha ha all right so here we go
all right oh it seems like we have a
spammer here let's see all right so
let's just block them here we go that
was then my block I'm permanently all
right okay so here we go
so all right next question so Christian
Chad again ask hi Jonathan
I've heard your nuanced position on
post-modernism and find it interesting
where a problem with post-modernism was
expressed by zero HP Lovecraft on
Twitter he says post-modernism is the
attempt of man laka booka Dada to
articulate and systematize a
fundamentally feminine way of being once
I read this I spoke to something deeply
true to me like how the feminine behaves
nonlinearly and unconsciously as opposed
to masculine linear rationality and
conscious what are your thoughts I think
that we still have a do we sell have
some kind of annoying spammer here all
right all right these guys
if there's a crazy spammer again just
tell me I'll try to I'll try to pay
attention to the I'll try to pay
attention to the chat a little more this
is new to me guys this whole thing so
let's hope that we won't go into hell in
the comments section all right okay so
um yes I think that that's that's an
interesting way to portray it you know
there's a there's a there's a funny
trope about there's a funny trope about
Jacques Derrida which is that he named
his sons their last names or family name
he named they're his sons after his
grandmother's name so his his
grandmother's a surname that's the name
that he gave to his sons and it's a
weird move like it's a because it's
still I mean it's still a masculine name
but it's like he tried to just go back a
few generations in order to break the
patriarchal patriarchal system and so
and so there is something that is quite
true about that and and I think that
that is also a a a problem you know the
the this the the the mystery of the
feminine like you said cannot be
systematized cannot be cannot be
articulated fully and the attempt to do
that is going to look something like
deconstruction is going to look it's
going to look like something that that
jugde ADA would do you know like I don't
know so much but for sure deed I would
say he kind of had that kind of had that
drive I I think as well and so so yeah I
think that's a good way it's it's one
way to kind of understand it you know
and I think that it's it's a it can be
helpful to think of it that way all
right okay so I'm going
now to patreon here you go
so pay enjo Terpstra asks what are your
thoughts on the on numerology
when does the meaningful numerology
become obscure how do you ago how do you
regard numerology in relation to grammar
and so he he gives me a he gives me a he
gives me an example of numerology a very
complicated one which I won't read you
know okay
what do I think of numerology man you
guys these question alright so I think
that numerology can be appropriate and
can be helpful the problem I think with
numerology is that at some point people
can start to to get fascinated with the
the pattern itself and not not be
interested in the meaning alright a
things growing out of control in this
Chad section here ya know what is going
on alright so I'm just gonna let this go
because I don't have no idea it's
getting out of control in this chat
section is there someone in
chat that I trust that I could put as a
moderator let's see it seems like it's
just all the same people that are all
right is is Jacob there Jacob are you in
the chat I don't know who you are
interpreter I'm not sure who you trust
he says all right hey is Kristian Chad
there all right I don't recognize any of
you guys is it Christian check all right
there's Christian chat all right hey
Christian would you be moderator here I
know it's annoying but I'm putting your
moderator now you have you have absolute
power all right at least for the worst
cases all right let's do it let's do
this all right so let me talk about
numerology this I'm not supposed to be
talking about all right
so numerology so the problem with
numerology is is when numerology is not
it's not pointing towards meaning and so
you can make the patterns are there I
don't think that that it's it's not true
they're there so you can add up words
and you can you if you use gamma tria
which is this equivalence between
especially in the Old Testament because
Hebrew the letters in Hebrew are also
numbers and so if you if if the letters
and you know that let's say in Hebrew
the the actual letters the way that you
would count would be to write letters
like if you you would if you'd be doing
math we would using letters to do math
because the letters also work as numbers
and so because of that there seems to be
the possibility that there are also
numerical patterns
in the text because of that reality
which is that in Hebrew both of those
functions together and so it gets
trickier in in in in Greek because
although Greek uses a Semitic alphabet
like a Phoenician alphabet it there's no
relationship between the alphabet that
it's using and the word it's like it's a
it's a transcription and so the in
Hebrew for example the ancient Hebrew
was almost here glyphic and so the
letters the letters and the words could
almost have sometimes a hero glyphic
meaning that the in that the words each
letter has a has a meaning in terms of
what it's it's a little drawing of
something and so those little drawings
are also part of the meaning of the
letters and ultimately possibly even the
meaning of the words but in Greek you
have this language Greek which lost its
writing and then adopted a semitic
writing in order Latin is a tool that
both Latin and Greek they adopted a
Semitic language in order to recover a
written language but so there's no
connection between the the written word
and the oral word and so it's it's
complicated but the early church fathers
do it anyways you know you read Irenaeus
you read the very early church fathers
and they do these types of calculations
in the in the text so I'm not saying
that it's impossible but I would say
that it's it's important to focus on if
you're gonna focus on numerology I would
say start by understanding the first
numbers like start by understanding what
one means what two three four yeah I
could say up to 12 maybe if you can
understand that first 12 numbers for
example and understand what they mean
metaphysically you know or
cosmologically is a better word maybe to
say you know that one is up also in
terms of geometry so you can understand
it like one is a point right - 2 is a
line or that connects two points then 3
is a triangle
four is a square five you know and so to
understand that as well then you can
start to understand also what the
numbers can
can mean all the way at least up to 12
so I would say it's better to do that
first rather than get into the really
complicated calculations because I would
say that although I do believe it's
possible and I do believe that you can
get some insight from that I've also
seen a lot of wackiness in people who
try to interpret numerology in the
biblical text you know they they they
they go off on crazy tangents and those
tangents are not sometimes not helpful
because they're not they're not pointing
you towards meaning they're not helping
you like they're not helping you move
towards something meaningful so I would
say start with that so maybe maybe one
day I could do a video on that kind of
do a basic video on on on the on the
meaning of 1 2 3 for example you know
that's a great that's a great thing to
understand so maybe I'll do that I won't
do that here because that would take a
while but but that might be an idea for
a video it's hope Andrew I hope that
understand that answers a question I'm
sorry I didn't read out your answer but
it would just if I read it out it would
just be gibberish to people because
there just be a bunch of of numbers I
don't think people would be able to
follow it in oral terms your example
alright so Robert Smits asks in your
video about ice cream licking these folk
of the problem of bringing the margins
into the center the election area for
this week included Leviticus 23 22 when
you reap the harvest of your land do not
reap the very edges of your field or
gather the gleanings of your harvest
yeah it's a really important text by the
way one might think that farmers could
most efficiently gather the gleanings
and be required by the law to perform
the charity of giving to the poor but
the law leaves the gathering of the
gleaning to the sinners themselves is
the law recognizing the inherent reflex
that if the farmers gather the gleanings
they might be tempted to keep it
themselves does this say something about
the efficiency of government versus
private charity
I don't know if it says something about
the efficiency of government versus
private charity but what it does
definitely say
talk about is the the problem of
accounting for everything the problem of
trying to account for everything and so
you know you you could see in this the
in this text you could see you know the
the what is it the how they call the
uncertainty principle or whatever know
this idea that you know I talked about
the fringe and I talked about how you
need to leave a fringe in order for the
world to exist properly if you try to
account for everything you try to fit
everything inside right so it's like you
have a field and you try to bring all
the grain into your barn then you will
not feed the sword owners you will not
feed the strangers you will not feed
those that are aliens in your land and
then that's a problem right that's a
problem because the the the margin the
marginal needs to to have a space in
them in the fringe and he needs to there
needs to be some things that are left in
the dark because because if you don't
leave room for them they're going to
build up and then they're going to
attack or they're going to they're going
to take over there it's not going to
it's not going to work and so the the
principle of leaving leaving the the the
corner of the field is the same
principle as having a narthex in the
church you know it's the same principle
as people as Persian rugs that they
leave a fringe on the edge of the
Persian Persian rug it's the same
principle as the fringes on the
vestments in the described in the Bible
as well
the idea of leaving a fringe on the edge
and that's really important you know I
talked about this before that one of the
reasons
you know one of the reasons for let's
say the pride movement is that early
modernism was the very opposite of that
early modernism was castrating gays was
was chemically castrating gays were
incarcerating pursuing people you know
going into the private life and and you
know revealing them and then and then
trying to to put them in asylums all
that type of stuff
they weren't leaving they weren't
leaving margins on the fringe and in
America people don't realize that
America is a is as this weird pendulum
that goes that goes back and forth that
only in America would there be on the
one hand you know what was it called now
my mind is blank when alcohol was
illegal
prohibition then on the one hand
there'll be something as insane as
prohibition and then on the other hand
there would be you know the 1960s and
and drug culture and and Ginni Garcia
and the Grateful Dead like that's
America you know and so because it's
swinging back and forth and so you you
have to leave room for the fringe and
just leave it as a fringe as long as as
long as it doesn't try to come in then
it's fine just leave it and and that's
part of the that's part of the idea of
leaving the edges of your field for
people to glean alright so XRD says
you're you mentioned your mention of
area on a grande in the ice cream like
liqueurs video that that comment just
wit i man I said that just you know at
the top of my head and then everybody
made comments about that thing but
anyways got me thinking about a recent
song by her god is a woman and the
spread of these goddess cult movements
yes which is a regression from all I
know have you done any talks or written
anything about the resurgence of these
if not any thoughts so I haven't talked
about this but I think that just like
the problem of just like the problem
that I mentioned before in terms of
terms of pride for example it's the same
problem the the modern world was it is
the modern enlightenment world is an
exclusively masculine idea it's an
exclusively masculine manifestation its
science its reason its conquering nature
its conquering its colonizing the world
bringing science and rationality to the
ends of the world mapping the entire
universe mapping you know making mapping
the human genome you know all that
mapping is a masculine action dominating
mapping all that and so the the first of
all of feminism and then God is a woman
type of thinking the resurgence of Wicca
and and all these weird kind of pseudo
feminine religious movements are a
reaction to that their reaction to the
over masculine and posed and the same
thing with the post-modernism like we
talked about how the Haddad is trying to
formulate a feminine mode of being and
the answer is that's true he's doing
that is dangerous and it's it's it it
actually can fragment society but you
can at the same time understand the urge
to do it because of the because of the
over masculine masculine overreach of
the Enlightenment and modernity and so
and so you know and my I think that it
starts with the Reformation I'm sorry to
say it starts with the Reformation and
the the the demonizing of the the Virgin
Mary and the casting aside of the Virgin
Mary within the story of the church
within the practices of the church
leaving no room for the feminine has I
think is what sparked this problem
moving and then moving up to today and
so on the one hand you know I'm not
obviously not justifying this nonsense
it's all nonsense
the
whicka and all this baloney I'm not
justifying it but I need we need to
understand the patterns by which even
the things we don't like we need to
understand that they don't come about
arbitrarily you know revolutions don't
come about arbitrarily we can be against
revolutions but we have to understand
that they are they're part of a pattern
if you don't understand that then we're
and we're going to be slaves to that
pattern alright so mark Peter says hello
Jonathan
in the last Q&A you made a statement
that in the West there is a tendency to
think of God as stasis versus in the
east as a dynamic community of love
minute ly the static God notion came out
of the West and one reaction to it was
the process theology of Alfred North
Whitehead where God is in the process of
becoming along with us however I'm much
more familiar with the philosophy and
theology that helped develop the idea of
person from explications of the Trinity
that God is immutable does not mean that
God is static here's where we get this
notion of the person Marc you're right
on target with what I was talking about
before so that doesn't mean that God is
static but that he is concrete as the
creator and sustainer of all beings so
he's intimately present to each of us in
a most perfect way I do see what you see
however my instinct is not to place
static distinctions between East and
West since unfortunately distinctions
like that tend to calcify into
separations and we need each other yeah
I mean sure that's fine you know I think
that I think for sure that the alfred
white north head response or his
solution to the problem i don't think
it's a good solution and it's like I
said I think that this static nature of
the interrelationship of the persons in
the Trinity should not be seen as change
in the way that we understand change in
a finite world we shouldn't we shouldn't
confuse that there are no there are no
Christian like Orthodox small oak
Orthodox Christian theologians who who
think that God is an is the process of
change or something like that
all right so drew McMahon asks during
the better left unsaid documentary
interview you were asked about strange
seeming contradictory aspects of Christ
like him saying I came to bring fire
pick up your sword Peter but then tells
him not to use it
etc and when interviewer asks you what
those mean you said you wouldn't answer
those mystical questions what's mystical
about it
can you answer it here why the hesitancy
so for that's the first part and then
similar to that topic in the same
interview you talked about I know I
talked about that in the shared
inheritance conference about knowing
people have tried hesychasm on their own
rather than with a church father but
went crazy can you talk about that more
I guess I mean that so the first
question what's mystical about it there
are some things about Christ that are
very difficult to talk about and I
usually I'll tell you you know it's like
the crucifixion is really hard to talk
about especially the crucifixion or just
a whole story of the crucifixion is very
difficult to talk about because it seems
like like Christ is is jamming the
entire cosmos into one event until all
the contradictions are being brought
into the story all these things are kind
of being played against each other being
resolved and so you know it's really
hard to to to talk about it because you
know on the one hand you have I talked
about this before you have Christ on the
cross dying but there's this image that
he's above he's above others and he's
also it says on his on the writing above
his head that he's the king but he said
mockingly but then it actually is true
and so it's like he's weird inversion
upon a virgin upon a virgin which
actually kind of brings everything
together the same when he's beaten he
they put the crown of thorns on him and
they beat him and they say they bow
before him and they say that he's the
king and so it's like they're actually
manifesting his kingship in the mocking
in the fact that they're mocking him as
a fake King there there
they're inadvertently it's flipping on
them and they're actually manifesting
his royalty I think while he's also
still going to the bottom it's like he's
going to the bottom but going to the top
at the same time and that's the cross
like it's the lowest and the highest
brought together you know he goes into
the Holy of Holies and then goes down
into Hades and so those things are
really hard to talk about and so I can
kind of point you in the direction but
I'm not encompassing the whole mystery
because the mystery is in the mystery
it's like I could point you to the two
opposites and tell you you know Christ
says bring a sword and then he says
don't use it Christ you know Christ you
know cry like I said Christ is crucified
as a thief but he's also the king he's
all this is going on at same time so I
can show you the opposites but I can't
show you how it comes together I can't
because that's an invisible thing it's
like this invisible place where all
these things are pointing to and they're
saying this spark this invisible mystery
I can't say it not because I don't want
to because I can't because it's not it's
beyond saying but I can show you all the
things that point to it and so in it's
in that sense that when I when I say
things like you know Christ says this
and then you said the opposite the the
create one of the craziest examples that
I can think of is in the Bible is Christ
says to Peter
he says you Peter you're the you're the
foundation you're the stone on which you
know I will build my church and it's
like then the next verse he says to
Peter get behind me Satan and it's like
right next to each other it's like one
verse next verse like how do you deal
with that how do you deal with that you
can't deal with that so it Christ does
that all the time he does these things
where he's showing you it's not it's
obviously not arbitrary it's not a it's
not an accident it's not a contradiction
in the simple sense where it's like he
says something and he says the other
thing and he doesn't know like he's
presenting you these two things and in
in in this weird extend these two
extremes and he's like you need to see
where they come together but I'm not
gonna I can't show that to you so
hopefully that's a good answer
hesychasm you know it's mostly that
hesychasm
is a very intense practice of continual
prayer and so what you're doing is
you're actually rewiring your entire
being so that it becomes this one prayer
until it is that you you repeat the
prayer so much you time it with your
breath with your heart with your
movements you know there's all these
stories of like that the father is there
let's say they're digging a hole and
they'll dig the hole with the prayer
it's like when they make this movement
this other movement it's like you know
inhale exhale all that is kind of coming
together they're basically trying to
rewire their being and so if you're not
if you're not being guided you can just
become schizophrenic I mean because it's
a dangerous thing to do like to actually
rewire your entire being it's very
dangerous and if you do it also without
someone if you don't connect yourself to
a hierarchy to a certain extent and
you're on your own doing it you're
you're don't you don't have a you don't
have the protection of a hierarchy you
don't have someone who's responsible for
you taking the responsibility away from
you saying this is this is I'm telling
you to do this this is not you it's not
pride because I'm the one telling you
and I could tell you to stop doing it
and you would have to obey so so it's
not pride because the problem is you do
it in pride then you will fall into all
kinds of excesses and you can lose
control now it does it mean that you
cannot say the Jesus Prayer you can say
it you can you can do the Jesus Prayer
for 15 minutes in the morning you can
you can do it you can say a hundred
times or 500 times or whatever you know
it's it's useful to do that you can also
use the Jesus Prayer when you're being
attacked by thoughts are attacked by by
certain desires you can use it to kind
of to kind of center yourself and and
come back into a it an attentive
prayerful mode all those things are fine
the problem that's not the problem the
problem is only the the the only the
only problem is the is the constant
prayer is the is really giving yourself
over to too
- doing it all the time non-stop you
know that's that's crazy I mean it's
dangerous so hopefully that answers that
you know but I hope people didn't think
that I was telling them not to do the
Jesus Prayer cuz you should you should
totally do it you should you should just
do it in a you should still do it in the
church you should still not just do it
on your own you should do it with some
one kind of guiding you following you
some you know a confessor or someone
someone who's who's who still your
authority even if they're not an actual
expert or a monk expert on that subject
so alright guys so alright so let's see
I am now I'm going into the super chats
so now I was able to find them so
alright so let's see let's go and go to
the first alright this is gonna work
guys okay so here we go so Michelle Alta
asks why was Hell created and how so
this is a really problematic question
because hell okay so what do you mean by
Hell so he'll he'll means death so hell
is Hades right so he'll means death and
there's a difference between death and
the river of fire you could call it you
know the the lake of fire that's
described in Revelation or that's
described by by Christ at some points
Gehenna
you could call it and so death itself is
a product of sin it wasn't created so
much as a side effect of of missing the
mark when you miss the mark things start
to break apart and you you decompose and
that's death that's why it's represented
in the ground you know that's why the
idea that hell that hell is below you
know it's down there
all these eldest imagery is to show you
that hell has to do with decomposition
has to do with breaking apart losing
cohesion losing memory losing connection
to your body between the body and the
soul something something like that
and so it's not that it was created it's
just that it is in it is a side effect
of sin it's a side effect of not of
missing the mark so I hope that answers
that question but so so the idea then of
the fire or the fire of Gehenna or the
river of fire that comes from the throne
of God that's more complicated because
to some extent there there's an idea
that that that fire is God or is the
presence of God and it's the presence of
God which is burning and I've talked
about this before it's that if you let
yourself be transformed you know if you
let go of your animosity if you let go
of your resentment if you let go and and
you you turn your self towards love then
the fire that comes from the throne of
God will be a deifying fire that that
fire will bring you closer well will
will consume you in a positive way will
consume you you know like like like a
like love like the love between two
lovers like that type of consuming but
the the fire can also burn you in the if
you refuse to be changed then that fire
is acting like coals on your head it's
burning you you know it's it's burning
you because you don't want God to see
you don't want to be transparent to
reality you don't want to be transparent
to God to the infinite you want to hold
on I want to hold on to your to your
thing to your pride to your whatever to
your little little idiosyncrasies you
want to hold on to them and so then here
comes this this this absolute you know
this fire that is absolute and is there
to to open up everything into to show
everything and you don't want you so
that's gonna burn you it's going to hurt
and so that that is a different that
seems to be the vision of Hell which
which the Orthodox are adopting mostly
so hopefully that answers that all right
can you expand on the vinegar that was
offered to Christ on the cross to me
this is Steven Anderson sorry Steven
Anderson asked and you spend on the
veneer that was offer to Christ on the
cross to me it seems like an inversion
of wine but just wondering what you made
of it I don't know if it's an inversion
of wine in the sense that it is it's
it's like it's it's an image of death
it's an image of wine that can't you you
can't drink anymore something like that
like death taken to the extreme tooth to
a point where you can't drink it anymore
and so that's that's what I would say
vinegar represents but I think that
there's probably multiple meanings for
vinegar out to be honest with you I
haven't thought about this so much all
right awesome well I guess I guess I'm
supposed to tell the amount Steven
Addison gave $5 Michelle Alta $3 USD the
mad truth five dollars Canadian you once
said that when you were that when you
were looking to join insurance you
bypass Catholicism because it was trying
too hard to be Protestant what did you
mean by this well I think it just
depends where you are but for sure in
Quebec the Catholic Church was trying to
be as informal as possible and so the
liturgy was reduced to the bare minimum
the priest was acting just as much like
an entertainer as I would see in
Protestant churches trying to get the
attention of the crowd by saying things
was constantly explaining things not was
breaking away from the liturgy
constantly breaking away from the
liturgy in order to explain or to give
their little comment or to whatever and
so I think that it's in that sense that
it was trying to be Protestant but I
don't think it's true
all Catholicism and I don't think in it
and it probably really depends where you
are and what kind of Catholicism is
around you but Vatican 2 and the spirit
of Vatican 2 we could call it seems to
have brought something like that about
so yeah so the mad truth for another $5
also ask what does New Age lack the
traditional religion possesses its lacks
cohesion it's a bunch of wages a bunch
of fragmentary knowledge is fragmentary
ideas fragmentary practices that are its
that are brought together you know New
Age is like a it's like a giant booyah
base you know like a big it's a pizza
China that s'what that's what pizza is -
food with new ages - religion no it's
like just put anything you want on it
just add a topping it's all good and so
it that's what it lacks it's just and so
the problem with that is is that it ends
up being an image of you you end up
taking all the little bits and parts
that fit you and then you put them
together you Cod you cobble them
together and you you kind of have all
these different practices but you're
gonna reach a wall because at some point
you need to transcend that those
idiosyncrasies and so you need an
authority you need something that is
higher than you something that can lead
you beyond those idiosyncrasies you know
and that's what hierarchy is for that's
what tradition is for you know and so
you have to not you don't argue with
tradition it's like because you don't
understand it that's the whole point you
in order for you to be able to get into
New Age and and and use it as a spirit
it's as if you would already have to be
spiritually enlightened enough to choose
your spiritual practices and then apply
them to yourself and so that just
doesn't doesn't work and it's the same
even if you find some random guru who
just shows up and you know he strikes
your fancy it's like it's the same
problem that it's not part of
of a bigger communion of people you know
anyway so that's that's that's the
problem
it lacks logos it's another way to say
it okay so TBA I for $5 US ask have you
ever come across the truth from a
metaphor where what happens in the
metaphor actually occurs
I really don't not sure I understand
that question I have I have a I have a
problem with the word metaphor and I've
expressed that several times I have a
problem with the notion of metaphor in
the sense of Brent Weinstein uses it I
don't think that he that that's a proper
way to view symbolism if what you mean
is symbolism happens then if you follow
my channel you know symbolism happens
that it in Evatt ibly happens and so
there are stories which are symbolic
which are that that are based on events
you know or that that gather events
together in a symbolic story or the
symbolic way of presenting and there are
some that it can be fictional you can
have a fictional story which is symbolic
you can have a and so it just depends on
the story and it depends on on what
happened but reality the world out there
is symbolic it's not arbitrary it's not
random it manifests itself in orderly
patterns to you that's how we and even
the disorderliness of it is part of the
pattern that's why I talk about the
fringe about about the edge about the
exception all of that is part of the
bigger pattern of being so TVA I for
another $5 u.s. says would you interpret
as above so below
and as within so without
how you interpret that I think that
Christ is the the example that the
example that I used before it's a good
example of as above so below or as
within so without would be the problem
of hypocrisy the problem of lying that's
what that's what Christ is so adamant
about breaking that pattern of lying and
of hypocrisy
because it is a disunity of heaven and
earth and so as above so below means
that the principle and the vehicle for
the principle the idea and the vehicle
for the idea the thought and the action
that which is invisible and that which
is visible are aligned and are united
together and so I think that all of that
is what I what it means by as above so
below and so it can it can take on all
kinds of forms in your own personal life
but also in terms of a society there are
ways to organize a society for it to be
harmonious and then that also becomes as
above so below we're by patterning
Society on spiritual principles that
society then will also function
adequately and when we go away from that
then we get totalitarianism we get
anarchy we get breakdown and that's when
it's not as above so below a great
example of not as above so below is
communism it's the best example of not
of the absolute disjunct between you
know as above so below and you can see
it that's why people are always saying
not real communism because they don't
understand that communism itself the
principles of communism in their
impossibility will manifest what they
manifest which is this disjunction
between the the theory and the practice
you know and so it will it will it will
say we're all equal and then it will
create a tyrannical system it will say
you know that it will bring prosperity
but it makes everybody poor will say oh
it will say things and then it will do
the opposite and and it will manifest
the opposite or the disjunction of what
it is saying and people think that it's
only because they weren't applied
properly but it's that no it's not the
case it's because the very ideas do
cannot find anchors there's there's
something off about the invisible part
of the of communism which
then makes the it makes it off when it
comes down to the world so alright so
Nick's Sherman for $10 ask me reconcile
the second commandment against graven
images versus iconography so that
seriously is not something that I could
do in the Q&A systematically I can
totally do it
but let's just I will do it very in a
very short manner but hopefully I can
make a video on that at some point and
the very short way in which I can
explain it is the reason why God said in
the second commandment not to make
images and not to make images of God
because there's something strange about
that do you ever notice that it says in
the Bible that human beings are made in
the image of God so why is it that God
says don't make images and the answer is
because God was going to give us an
image God was going to give us an image
in the person of Jesus Christ that is
that the Christ is the visible image of
the invisible father and so you have a
problem which is if I had a picture of G
of Jesus like if I have been able to
think of a picture like a photo of Jesus
I could I could show it to you and if I
ask you this question if I said can you
recognize Jesus and you say yeah yeah
Eric and I Jesus so is this a picture of
God how would you answer that question
it's tough and so that was the struggle
at the beginning of the church is how do
we deal with this problem which is that
in first century Galilee you could point
and say hey where is God and you could
say there's God you could
quite to Jesus and his face is the face
of God how do you deal with that and so
that's so the early church struggled and
there was a war there you know there was
an iconoclastic controversy where there
is a war between factions because it was
so important to understand it and the
the conclusion is is extremely important
the conclusion is not only that it's
permitted to make images of Christ but
that if you do not make images of Christ
if you refuse to do so you are in some
respects denying an aspect of in the
Incarnation you are saying that Christ
did not have an image that Christ did
not have a physical body that that that
Christ the man who was also God could
not be seen and touched and and in the
world and so that is why there are icons
because in the end the second
commandment is a promise that God would
give us that image and to have icons is
to answer the second commandment by
saying and this is how they ended up
answering it is that we do not make
images of God
we represent the person of Jesus Christ
we do not represent his divinity
we represent his image as a testimony as
their as a testimony to the reality of
the Incarnation and to the extent to
which we also are in that restored image
of Christ then that that not only opens
up but makes the image part of the the
the revelation that God put in Christ
that the image is part of that that I
can say that's Christ is this a picture
of Christ yes and I tell people like
even the most iconic lassic Protestant
you have a book with a picture of Jesus
for kids and you ask the kid hey who's
that and the kid would would they get
their gonna answer
oh that's Jesus you have to deal with
that theologically you have to deal with
that and the and iconography has been
the way that
Church has has dealt with it so that's
the short answer for now and maybe one
day I'll make a longer video on that so
Christian Chad for $5 says hi Jonathan
thanks for endow me with absolute power
over the chat I promise to be a fair and
generous Lord I Kris I with with your
name Christian I totally trust you to be
that so alright let's see if a few
others came in while I was talking all
right so I see more people have come all
right let's see all right so so the
golden thread for $10 ask I see you have
a playlist on mimetic theory any
thoughts on Gerard's or Eric Gans ideas
that are ready to articulate I think
they provide a fruitful amendment to
your dialogue with neuropsych types yeah
I just did a interview with an expert on
Avenida ha
he I think it's if you found that
playlist on my youtube channel it's the
guy who made those videos I interviewed
him we did we had a really great
conversation about jihad and so I'll
probably be putting that up next week or
in a few weeks I'm not sure I got I've
got all I've got videos kind of piling
up and so either next week
this week or next week I will put out
that discussion and I think it will I
think that there's some interesting
things to look at in general like I
don't agree with everything that he says
but for sure I think that there's some
interesting some things think so
so tbh AI for $5 asks why do some have a
flat earth perspective so I have said
many times and I will say it again that
the reality is that most of the time the
earth is flat not always but most of the
time it's flat and so the problem with
flat earthers is that they're
materialists and that's the problem is
that is that that they're materialist
and they're trying to deal with a world
of meaning and their materialism is
clashing so they're trying to kind of
fit it together make it work
in terms of the phenomenology and the
existence in the world of meaning and
this kind of scientific understanding
and they're not seeing that you don't
necessarily have to to put them on the
same level that that you can say
something like most of the time view
earth is flat that the sky is up that
the Sun rises in the morning all those
things are absolutely true and they're
the most true because if you don't do
them in the mental gymnastics of
imagining that no the Sun isn't rising
in the morning it's actually you know
it's actually the earth that's turning
and and so you don't do that you just
say the earth is that the Sun is coming
up in the morning and your entire world
is patterned on that reality you base
your day and your nights your sleep your
eating patterns all of that is based on
the fact that the Sun comes up in the
morning and new and it's up in the sky
and then it goes it goes down in the
evening and you go to bed so that has
more meaning and so that to me is the
problem so I did a video on that the
symbolic meaning of Flat Earth and so
you can check that out if you want you
so Chris and Chad for five dollars he
says just to follow up what are the
negative consequences of systematizing
articulating the feminine mystery why do
postmodern thinkers do this so the
negative consequences of systematizing
the feminine mystery is that it will end
up being a kind of a kind of
desacralization egg you know it'll end
up being a okay so there are things
which are true which when they are when
they are uttered can become untrue and
so
this is this is this is the this is the
the this is the problem let's say it's
very clear like in Saint Ephrem the
Syrian in st. gregory of nyssa and st.
maximus the confessor and all the saints
that i that i espouse and i look at its
it's very true to say that the purpose
of creation is so that god would unite
himself to his creation and that
creation would become God by
participation and so the purpose of
creation is is a form of deification
right and there's there's nothing weird
about saying that in a strictly Orthodox
perspective but if you say I am God
that's not the same that's not the same
that's the devil that's that's Adam's
sin
that's all that's wrong about our world
and so there's some things which cannot
be uttered and and and their aspects of
the feminine mystery which should not be
uttered and should remain should remain
a mystery and we saw that problem even
the Orthodox Church with a movement
called Sophie ology where certain
theologians tried to articulate the
feminine aspect of the divine and did so
in a manner which I think had that very
effect to betray the mystery and to and
to to expose something which was ended
up looking shameful when it was exposed
but is not shameful in its miss in its
mysterious form you could say that's the
only thing I guess I can say about that
so why do post
thinkers do this yeah I mean they want
to it's a revolutionary move it's still
a revolutionary move even though they
don't say it is so Chloe Goodman for $5
USD ass can you talk more about hell and
ego how to get away from hell and start
living you can follow Jesus I mean those
these huge questions like how can I get
away from hell and start living my
goodness I mean you I mean the only
answer I can give you is to to to take
up your cross to follow Christ to to
enter into the communion of the saints
you know learn to love your neighbor I
mean I'm just gonna repeat what Jesus
said you know that that's the way you
know and so the problem of Christianity
in terms of ego does see there that
there's a certain emptying which is
necessary of the ego and that's the
whole idea of humility the idea all of
that that you have to learn to empty
yourself of of your ego to a certain
extent because your ego there's nothing
wrong with your ego but it can be an
obstacle to the Neuse because it thinks
that it's all in all you know it thinks
that all those thoughts of yours you
think that they're you but they're not
you not at least not the totality of you
you know you you exist beyond your
thoughts and your passions and all these
things and so that's part of the
emptying of the of the of the ego all
right guys I think let me just check
again but I think we're gonna we're
gonna rot wine down so we get so got a
few more all right so I think these are
gonna be the last one so guys don't
don't don't add any more so think are
gonna be done so the mad truth asks for
five dollars I've noticed Protestant
churches take
the so-called social justice where your
cause in its contemporary ideological
form why would this be this is something
you know I talked about this discussion
I did with Anthony Jia I think you'll
get the answer to that in that talk I'll
be putting it out soon it has to do with
the fact that in social justice ideology
there is something which on the first
glance people can think looks like
Christianity there is in Christ this
notion of the innocent victim and that
is part of of Christ and so the this the
social justice mentality takes up the
notion of the innocent victim but then
uses it as a club to attack others you
know and so uses it as a manner to give
themselves power in order to to destroy
in order to take down the hierarchy the
revolutionary tendency and so people can
be duped into thinking that that caring
for that which is marginal you know
giving to the poor helping the widow all
of that helping the sick helping the
needy visiting people in prison all of
the things that Christ told us to do you
know which is this this connection to
the victims of society this this
capacity to to bring them to chew to to
give them love and to to make them
participate in the the whole thing that
what they're doing they think that
that's what they're doing they think
that that by engaging in in political
action by engaging in these
demonstrations by fighting for the
rights of all these different
marginalized groups they think that that
it's the same and
and the difference is maybe too subtle
for them to notice the difference
between helping the poor you know and
and the poor guillotining the rich those
two things are not the same you know
that caring for someone who is a sinner
caring for someone who is marginalized
but not that doesn't mean that then
their margin marginal identity should
redefine the normal world you know those
two things are very different and so I
think that that we can understand why
they fall in in that vein but but it's a
it's they're being duped so Rob Smith
were $4.99 USD ask opinion on Oedipus
complex totem and taboo so I'm not sure
what you mean by totem and taboo like I
don't know exactly what you're asking in
terms of Oedipus complex I mean I don't
know I I find these things very
uninteresting you know I prefer the
story of Oedipus to the Oedipus complex
the story of Oedipus is is a very
profound story that that you could talk
about maybe I'll make that one of my
patron videos but I think that I think
that the that I think I'm not saying
that there isn't something in Freud that
you can that you can get from from Freud
because in Freud there is a kind of
weird attempt at symbolic thinking but
it's usually very upside down and and
and I think that for example
understanding the the question of
Oedipus and of incest in the terms that
I present the more in the terms that my
brother might represent them gives far
more fodder than then Freud's Oedipus
complex it can help you understand
problems of causality you know if you
watch my cannibal babies video I talked
about the problem of
of cannibalism incest sodomy all these
things have to do with self reference
and breaking down of normal causality
which brings about which means about
chaos and so and so you can check that
out if you want all right guys I I think
that I think that we're done so yeah so
I think I was able to stay on top of
these of these super chats this time so
I so I appreciate you guys coming out we
have 165 people which is cool most
people I think bit more than even than
last time so so maybe I will continue to
do it this way and Christian Chad maybe
can be my official moderator if you show
up I might I might maybe I'll post on
the Facebook group because I trust a lot
of those guys and see you know who's
gonna be there and wanting to be to be
moderator because we didn't want to keep
the crap out of out of the out of the
out of the chat so sorry guys it was
great to talk to you good questions stay
tuned for more videos and all that stuff
and I will see all of you very soon so
bye everybody